Jim just a fuss
the Empire's building a weapon capable
of destroying an entire planet they call
it the Death Star need to capture the
plants if there's any hope of destroying
it we want to help all right how many do
I need I'll be there for you the captain
said I had to tell them but we are
dealing with you is immeasurable I'll
not fail
the Imperial forces are converging on
our present location
take hold of this moment
the force is strong
tell me you have a back-up plan
punch it
may the force be with us
rogue one a Star Wars story
you almost got me no well car radio
pg-13
hey youtubers is Charlie new rogue one
footage so let's break it down there's
also a whole bunch of Jedi stuff in here
that we haven't talked about in previous
trailers so the trailer is all about
trusting each other trusting the force
but the force part of that is a much
bigger deal and we actually see Jin with
like a little crystal around her neck
the Kyber crystals were actually being
mined from the special Jedi planet there
are two big locations that we've seen in
all these trailers aside from the actual
interior of the Death Star there's the
tropical planet which is scarf which is
actually where the Death Star's being
built then there's the planet where
they're mining the Kyber crystals from
which is called Jed ha and it's actually
a term that's taken from some of Lucas's
original work you know original word for
the Jedi it was something that was
created for this movie like it didn't
exist in the Star Wars universe before
they wrote the story for Star Wars rogue
one but it's meant to be this special
moon that's kind of like a holy place
like Jerusalem or Mecca that Jedi would
go on pilgrimages to there's a holy city
there that we see in this trailer that's
like a very sacred city but there are
Kyber crystals there so during the fall
of the old republic in the rise of the
empire they started to use it to mine
for crystals to create the Death Star
super laser so you know this really WTF
desecration of this galactic holy site
so for those of you wondering this
wasn't something that showed up in the
original Star Wars films or even the
prequels this is something they're
weaving into the mythology but there
were always places that the Jedi would
go to search for force crystals to make
their lightsabers so one of the most fun
things for me when I go see this movie
is gonna be trying to pick out the new
bits of mythology they try to weave in
that will also be present in the new
Saga films like in the way during
episode 7 Luke Skywalker had gone on a
pilgrimage to try and find the original
Jedi Temple we see a whole bunch more
k2s oh I can already sense he's going to
be one of my favorite new characters so
hopefully if he doesn't get blown to
smithereens he'll show up in the new
films too but that's another thing too
there been talked that they're not gonna
do Saga films anymore after episode 9
but they'll still be doing Star Wars
movies it's just that when they said
that they might not do Saga films
anymore they were talking about
trilogies especially ones that follow
the Skywalker family so you guys can let
me know
think about that because if they did do
that then they would do more films like
this just a really big story from the
Star Wars universe but a relatively
self-contained one but they all would
still be in the same continuity so you
might see characters from one movie pop
up in another but it wouldn't
necessarily be like a beginning middle
and through three films it would just be
like this continuing story is they jump
around the galaxy and jump around in the
timeline but personally I would really
like to see them try to go back into the
past at least once for like an Old
Republic movie like a Knights of the Old
Republic movie would be so badass after
episode 9 because you can still do a lot
of the same really awesome things that
you do in Star Wars films but with
completely different characters in a
time and a setting that we've never
really seen before in the Star Wars
movies but I know this is like the trust
trailer so on the flip side is so funny
to see cranek asking for Darth Vader's
trust in if you've seen episode 4 you
know that Darth Vader was not impressed
with the Death Star he's like this is
nothing compared to the power of the
force so we might see a version of that
conversation in the movie where he tries
to appeal to Vader in Vader just
completely shuts him down but because of
the weird position that Vader holds
inside the Empire he's kind of off on
his own he oversees things but he's also
in charge of destroying the rebellion so
most of his interest in this story isn't
racking down the rebels he probably
barely cares about the construction of
the Death Star like the only other big
story that I would really like to see
out of him in this is him at this Jedi
holy place on the jet ha planet because
he would have an interest in them mining
Kyber crystals even if he wants to crush
the Jedi Order he still respects the
force like he still has reverence for it
so he might be horrified that they're
trying to destroy this special jedi
place hopefully they don't blow it up
when they test that super laser but I
think this is gonna be a lot of fun I'm
mostly interested in how they made this
just as much as I am in the actual story
itself and they did post like a
behind-the-scenes featurette so if you
haven't seen it here it is right here
but nine since I was four hours
gonna be shooting a Star Wars film I
would have planned it all my life this
film this character is a story I grew up
with it's a whole world I've been
thinking about it for quite a long time
you can feel everyone in the career in
the cars kind of stops and just take
that in and you remember oh actually in
Star Wars it's like the world's greatest
toy said it's a bit like being that kid
again
the Star Wars figures still troopers
over here and this happens there's an
explosion it's been a lot of fun it's
the greatest job in the world
broke one takes place very close to
episode 4 the simplest way to explain
that is that text you see at the
beginning of a new hope that is
essentially a moving
they call it the death star terrible
weapon if there's a way to defeat him
gin starting to put together a team
wants to fight we all do
I'm only doing it it is an ensemble
movie but at the heart is a strong woman
the time to fight is now every day they
grow stronger
all these characters are real heroes
that are willing to risk everything like
the place huh I make 10 men feel like a
hundred through their journey we see the
formation of the Rebel Alliance and
stealing of the Death Star plans and you
are not willing to risk be left behind
as your chance to speak up that is a bad
idea they achieve what they achieved
because they achieve it together this is
one
I know the Droid is gonna be a lot of
fun in this but watching Donnie Yen in
all these clips just gets me super hype
about badass ninja Jedi skills he's
blind in the movie and he's technically
not a Jedi but he's basically the Obi
one of the group the mystic who trusts
in the force whereas at least at the
beginning of the movie everyone else is
on the fence about it you know more like
Han Solo at the beginning of episode
four
cut to Episode seven and he is a full-on
believer in the power of the force so
Donnie Yen is gonna be amazing in this
and let's not forget about Mass
Mickelson who just showed up in Doctor
Strange this character I think is gonna
be a little more fully formed his Doctor
Strange character was really cool but it
fell prey to the common problem in big
superhero movies with underdeveloped
villains the character he's playing on
this is someone who's presented with the
impossible situation save his family by
having to work for the empire so he has
to help build the Death Star which is
this terrible weapon of mass destruction
but if he doesn't his family will die so
even though his Doctor Strange character
was really cool I think he's gonna be
much cooler in rogue one so what's gonna
happen when the movie gets here I'll do
my review video like I would normally do
I'll do Easter eggs in stuff for episode
8 if there are any special Star Wars
bonus videos you guys want me to start
doing just let me know in the comments
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and if you're looking for a really good
story to read to get ready for rogue one
that's part of the canon catalyst is the
new novel they just released it is a
rogue one prequel so it's not like crazy
bigs not a huge time investment but if
you want to read classic comics to get
into the history of the Jedi just really
big deep cuts I'd recommend Golden Age
of the Sith or tales of the Jedi Dark
Lords of the Sith the Sith war
technically they're not canon anymore
but they're still like really awesome
stories about Jedi history Jedi and Sith
history specifically tomorrow is going
to be Walking Dead game of Thrones and
then Westworld will be on Monday so get
height it's gonna be awesome what you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my Captain Marvel most powerful
character video and you can click here
for that flash arrow extended trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight me